bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir et de revoir les temps
forts de la dernière session
parlementaire avec un focus aujourd'hui
sur le projet de loi Macron projet de
loi croissance activité égalité des
chance économique un texte qui a
définitivement été adopté par le
Parlement au début du mois de juillet
mais qui a donné lieu à de très longs
débats que cela soit au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale focus aujourd'hui
sur l'un des temps fort de la première
lecture de ce texte au Sénat l'adoption
d'un dispositif antiogle par la Haute
Assemblée en effet si le géant américain
n'est jamais explicitement mentionné
dans le texte il n'est fait nul doute
que c'est bien lui qui était visé par
l'amendement de Catherine Morin de sali
sénatrice centriste également présidente
de la commission de la culture cette
mesure a trouvé un large écho au Sénat a
été adopté à une large majorité
elle stipulait que Google devait sur sa
page d'accueil afficher trois liens vers
des moteurs de recherche différents
c'est une mesure à laquelle le ministre
de l'Économie Emmanuel Macron était très
largement défavorable en effet il a jugé
à la fois inconstitutionnel et contraire
au droit européens tout de suite donc
retour au débat dans l'hémicycle nous
passons euh un article additionnel avec
le 995 rectifié bis madame Maurin de s
vous avez la parole merci Monsieur le le
Président on a beaucoup parlé du
déploiement des réseaux essentiel au
développement de notre économie
aujourd'hui je vrais qu'on parle un
petit peu des des usages et de la
maîtrise de l'écosystème tel que il fait
vivre désormais toute notre économie les
craintes face au pouvoir de monopole des
géants de l'internet américain ne cesse
de croîre en France et en Europe pas
seulement en France et en Europe mais
également aux États-Unis où il y a
quelques semaines la très offficielle
FTC qui est l'autorité de régulation a
mis en exerg les parties
anticoncurrentielles du moteur de
recherche
Google après une enquête qui d'ailleurs
a été enterrée en 2013 des collègues
sénateurs américains sont en train
d'enquêter
là-dessus en novembre dernier le
Parlement européen avait adopté une
résolution pour la défense des droits
des consommateurs sur le marché
numérique qui appelait la Commission
européenne à envisager des propositions
afin de mieux séparer les moteurs de
recherche d'autres services appartenant
à ces mêmes groupes cette préoccupation
concernant les moteurs de recherche
s'explique tout simplement par le fait
qu'ils sont la principale porte d'entrée
à Internet ce sont des acteurs
structurants ce sont des acteurs qui
constituent des infrastructures
incontournables désormais or le camp
comportement de ces acteurs structurants
pte parfois atteinte au pluralisme des
idées et des opinions nué à l'innovation
et entrave la liberté d'entreprendre et
de commercer la question de la loyauté
de ses opérateurs à à l'égard des
acteurs français et européens est
essentielle comme l'a relevé le Conseil
d'État dans son étude annuelle 2014 le
numérique et les droits fondamentaux le
projet de loi qui nous intéresse pour la
croissance l'activité l'égalité des
chances économiques qui vise justement à
établir une concurrence saine sur
plusieurs marchés susceptibles de
libérer l'activité économique et de
créer de l'emploi ne peut laisser de
côté le secteur du numérique qui
constitue un des principaux relais de
croissance économique à dire le
numérique c'est pas une seule industrie
c'est aujourd'hui et demain toutes les
industrie c'est la préoccupation du
Sénat exprimé en particulier ces
dernières ces derniers mois à travers un
rapport d'une mission commune
d'information sur le nouveau rôle et la
nouvelle stratégie pour l'Union
européenne dans la gouvernance de
l'Internet qui dit que l'Europe ne peut
rester une colonie du monde numérique et
qu'il est plus que temps que nos
sociétés de plus en plus dépendantes à
l'Internet réagissent il est donc urgent
de se donner les moyens d'encadrer les
pratiques de ces moteurs de recherche
compte tenu des conséquences néfastes et
avérées qu'occasionnent certaines de
leurs pratiques pour l'innovation pour
nos entreprises pour les consommateurs
bien sûr cet objectif passe par la mise
en place d'une régulation exantée le
classement des résultats par un moteur
de recherche conditionne très largement
la visibilité effective d'une
information sur Internet et partant
l'attention que lui porte l'internaute
or ce dernier a tendance à accorder une
confiance abusive dans les résultats des
algorithmes perçus comme objectif et
infaillible notamment car il ne dispose
d'aucune information quand au méth
utiliser et que du fait d'accord
d'exclusivité il n'a parfois pas d'autre
choix que de se référer au résultat d'un
unique moteur c'est un amendement
important monsieur le Président d'accord
ou en outre par le trouchement du
paramétrage de son algorithme et dans C
je ne peux pas vous laisser continuer
veillez conclure en de mots général
d'utilisation un moteur de recherche
peut refuser de référencer ou de classer
ou bien de déréférencer ou déclasser
tout site internet tout cela pour dire
que le présent amendement vise justement
à préserver la liberté d'entreprendre
des opérateurs économiques français l'
existence numérique qui bien sûr en
découle et confie un rôle de régulation
et de contrôle à l'autorité idouine qui
est l merci alors sur cet amendement a
été déposé un sous-amendement
1792 par Monsieur Assouline vous avez la
parole en 3 minutes oui oui non très
rapidement parce que il y aura d'autres
interventions mais c'est un sujet qu'à
la commission culture nous partageons
depuis longtemps et qui est euh euh
cette grande difficulté avec l'avance et
maintenant le monopole qu'on quasiment
acquis des des des entreprises aussi
verticales que Google euh de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait des régulations
notamment qui contreviennent pas au
droit européens auquel nous sommes
soumis même si très souvent nous avons
tel ou tel désaccord avec lui et donc
cet amendement vient euh euh manifester
cette volonté politique unanime
notamment dans le domaine culturel dans
le domaine de l'information parce que on
voit à quels abus tout cela conduit y
compris à euh
euh aller jusqu'à capter une grande
partie de ce qu'est euh la création
française et ses
droits j'ai voulu le sous-amender pour
renforcer cette volonté puisque qu'il
s'agit de dire pour Madame main de sa
qu'il faut au moins trois moteurs de
recherche proposé qu'il y en ait au
moins un c'est ma précision dont le
siège social soit en France ce qui
permet de d'aller dans le sens et de
préciser cette volonté de
encourager
la les entreprises françaises et
notamment
ceux qui en France se positionnent sur
ce créneau donc c'est rien de
contradictoire je veux juste dire tout
de même que j'ai conscience complètement
que tant dans l'amendement de Madame
Maurin de sa que dans mon
sous-amendement il y a surtout une
volonté politique parce qu'en terme de
droit européen voire même de droit
constitutionnel
su
c'est c'est pas sûr que ça tienne
complètement
mais je je tiens à dire que cette
manifestation et cette volonté politique
doit être affirmée ici et c'est pour
cela que je m'inscris dans l'amendement
de madameous mais la
réalité c'est que nous cherchons parce
que nous avons ce retard et parce qu' a
ce monopole sans arrêt à réguler avec
des barrières qui tombent devant leur
puissance or
l'Europe depuis bientôt 10 ans aurait dû
s'engager dans le fait de mettre un vrai
concurrent en face et si tous les États
européens si tous les savoir-faire les
scientifiques la la la la
masse potentielle de l'Europe dans le
domaine du numérique où on pourrait être
les premiers si on savait s'unir mettez
en face de Google un concurrent
peut-être que Google n'aurait pas ce
monopole donc il faut réguler mais il
faut surtout maintenant accélérer le
fait qu'au niveau européen il y ait de
la mise en commun et je pense que pour
ce que ce sera le numérique dans 10 ans
si on le fait maintenant peut-être qu'on
sera devant Google peut-être qu'on sera
devant tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont ce monopole en ce qui
concerne le numérique au plan
international donc il y a pas que la
régulation je suis d'accord qu'on le
fasse mais il y aura ce qu'on doit faire
au niveau concret au niveau économique
pour qu'il y ait une vraie concurrence
en face ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui alors quel est l'avis de la
commission
madame alors sur le sous-amendement la
commission spéciale n'a pas pu
l'examiner puisqu'il vient d'être il
vient nous être distribué comme ça au
piedev si je peux employer cette
expression un peu un peu triviale il
nous semble que la conformité avec le
droit européen de la concurrence est
très incertain monsieur assouine l'a dit
en argant du fait que certes c'était
vraisemblablement le cas mais que c'est
également le cas de celui de Madame main
de sa ce qui est peut-être un peu moins
sûr et si tel est le cas nous pensons
que c'est pas la peine d'en rajouter en
incertitude par rapport au droit
européen de la concurrence et donc une
demande de retrait et sinon ce sera un
avis défavorable merci et
celui le
9595 donc cet amendement traite d'un
nouveau sujet qui ne figurait pas dans
le texte à ce stade ça a été dit celui
des moteur de recherche et de la façon
dont il traitent et livre l'information
à leurs utilisateurs nous savons t tous
qu'un de ces moteurs de
recherche exerce une position dominante
sur le marché français notamment transit
en fait par lui la très grande majorité
des demandes de recherche formulées par
les internautes or cet éditeur de
service est régulièrement mis en cause
pour un traitement biaisé entre
guillemets des informations qui le
conduirait à ne pas faire preuve d'une
totale objectivité dans les résultats
qu'il fournit à ses utilisateurs en
mettant d'abord en avant soit ses
propres services soit des opérateurs
qu'il a comme clients il en résultera
ainsi une certaine tromperie de l'usager
qui pense que les résultats de la
recherche sont parfaitement objectifs et
rationnels alors que le moteur
privilégie certains au détriment
d'autres selon son seul intérêt il en
résulte également une mise à l' à
l'écart des acteurs de l'Internet qui ne
rentrent pas dans le jeu du moteur
dominant et se trouve déclassé dans les
résultats de recherche ce qui signifie
pour eux une mort économique à plus ou
moins long terme pour y faire face le
présent amendement propose de respecter
des obligations de transparence de
loyauté et de non discrimination dans le
fonctionnement de tout moteur de
recherche dominant et assorti C
obligation de sanction pécunière sur le
principe nous sommes tout à fait
favorables à cet amendement cependant il
y avait des interrogations sur son
applicabilité puisqu'il est assez
intrusif dans le fonctionnement du
moteur dominant visé et peut-être
pourrait brouiller la lisibilité de ces
résultats par les internautes et entre
et en are je l'ai déjà évoqué nous avons
du mal à apprécier la robustesse
juridique de l'amendement au regard
notamment du principe de liberté de
commerce c'est pourquoi la Commission
spéciale Co quoi que bienveillante sur
le principe de l'amendement sen est tenu
un avis de
sagesse très bien monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président j'auris
j'aurais sur ces deux amendements une
demande de
retrait pourquoi je pense que si vous ne
les retirez pas ils seront votés de
toute façon puisque
cela c'est satisfaisant de s'exprimer
face à Google et donc vous n'allez pas
réussir a réprimé cet enthousiasme
collectif maintenant que je me suis
habitué à vous
donc donc voilà mais donc je veux
néanmoins plaider pour expliquer
pourquoi je pense que le retrait est une
meilleure formule d'abord il s'est en
effet passé hier quelque chose la
Commission européenne a pris ses pleines
responsabilité il faut lui reconnaître
après la sisine et une procédure qui a
commencé en 2010 vous avez raison Madame
la sinatrice c'est vrai madame la
Présidente je vous reconnait ce point
nous avons constamment poussé à tous les
niveaux pour que cette décision soit
prise mais elle est importante nous
avons accompagné les 18 opérateurs
français qui ont mené cette action
contre Google et donc hier la Commission
a trouvé suite aux investigations une
base pour
véritablement précisément contraindre
Google à clarifier ses Orient clarifier
véritablement ses engagements et a
annoncé avoir notifié à Google des grifs
sur sur le comparateur de prix alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ils se sont aperçus ils ont pu
montrer que l'algorithme a favorisé le
comparatif comparateur de prix Google
indépendamment de ses performances que
ça l'avait favorisé et que ce faisant et
que ce faisant ça avait conduit à
améliorer les performances du
comparateur de prix et donc à le
discriminer par rapport aux autres
acteurs ce qui est un point important il
y a en même temps les actions qui sont
conduites sur Android et donc la
plateforme mobile et là c'est une
procédure for qui a été ouverte donc la
Commission européenne prend ses
responsabilités la commissaire westager
mène cette action et le gouvernement a
constamment pris ses responsabilités
pour pousser la Commission en ce sens
moi dans tous les contacts que j'ai eu
avec la Commissaire je l'ai à chaque
fois rappelé nous avons été très
exigeants avec le commissaire Almunia à
la fin de son précédent mandat pour
qu'il n'y ait pas un compromis Atif qui
soit trouvé avec les opérateurs sans
test de marché ce qui avait été à un
moment la proposition qui était faite et
donc nous continuons à avancer pourquoi
parce que le sujet et c'est finalement
ce pourquoi essentiellement je vais
aller dans les détails mais moi je vous
incite au retrait sur cet amendement et
vous le savez vous le savez madame la
Présidente c'est un sujet européen le
bon niveau à la fois en terme de
compétenence et de taille critique ça
n'est pas le niveau national ça n'est
pas le niveau national et vous l'avez
vous-même écrit dans votre rapport en
mars 2013 je vous cite l'échelon
national n'est assurément pas l'échelon
pertinent pour appréhender la révolution
numérique seul l'Union européenne à la
masse critique pour peser dans le
cyberespace et c'est vrai parce que la
bonne compétence par rapport au problème
que vous voulez attraper c'est la
Commission européenne c'est d'ailleurs
sa compétence exclusive en fait la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est le bon
niveau on peut s'amuser à envoyer des
signaux très forts face à Google on le
fait mais prendre des textes comme on
l'avait voulu à un moment le faire avec
la taxe Google c'est s'exposer à des
mesures parfois de représail unilatéral
sur des acteurs français et c'est créer
des biais dans l'avancée européenne il
faut continuer ce travail et pour
convaincre les autres on va dans
quelques semaines faire proposer un
texte au-delà des engagements déjà pris
par nos chef d'État et de gouvernement
une stratégie numérique
franco-allemande pour que début mai la
Commission européenne qui prendra sa sa
stratégie numérique puisse être éclairé
par le tandem franco-allemand c'est la
bonne méthode pour avancer c'est la
c'est la seule méthode efficace parce
que aussi pour ces acteurs qui sont
devenus des plateformes mondiales et
d'ailleurs dont les pays d'origine se
posentour aujourd'hui la même question
que les États-Unis se se posaient il y a
plus d'un siècle sur Standard Oil qui
est celui du démantelllement ces pays on
crée des champions dont les marchés
critiques ne sont pas à la taille d'un
état c'est le marché européen qui est le
bon marché si on veut pardon de cette
expression mais faire mal à Google donc
je pense que l'instrument que vous
utilisez le le point d'entrée qui est le
vôtre est largement imparfait et nous
déstabiliserait dans cette action
groupée constamment au niveau européen à
travers nos acteurs que nous défendons
et avec lesquels nous poussons à travers
ce dialogue avec la Commission
européenne et la stratégie numérique
ensuite vous proposez d'encadrer le
comportement des moteurs de recherche en
mettant un régime d'obligation de
sanction bon je vais là quand même
rentrer dans le détail parce que je sais
que vous êtes sensible à la fabrique du
droit j'ai aussi beaucoup appris depuis
10 jours et donc et c'est pas fini et
donc d'abord pour qualifier
juridiquement un effet structurant sur
les l'économie qui entraînerait
l'opposition l'imposition d'une
obligation on peut se rattacher au droit
de la concurrence mais dans ce cas nous
sommes ramenés au régime actuel et on
pourra y revenir dans le débat le droit
sectoriel comme celui des télécom il
recourt quant à lui à des analyses
exhaustif des marchés en cause avant
d'imposer des remèdes parce qu'il est
repose sur la base du droit européen et
donc je pense que par la qualification
que que vous prenez de de l'effet
structurant sur l'économie vous ne
pouvez reprendre une simple notion de
droit de la concurrence parce que vous
êtes sur le secteur des des télécom et
donc on devrait aller plus loin ensuite
il y a quatre types
d'obligation il me semble que la
première elle est à la fois peu
praticable et sans doute
disproportionnée c'est précisément celle
qui consisterait en quelque sorte à
demander à Renault d'afficher sur son
pare-brise le fait qu'il est aussi
possible d'acheter une Peugeot à une
Fiat
c'est en quelque sorte sur sur le moteur
de recherche et le BIA sur le
comparateur de prix c'est exactement ce
que que la Commission vient de pointer
en demandant une obligation excantée
telle que vous le le tel que vous le
proposez je pense que vous allez à la
fois trop loin et en même temps ce sera
peu praticable il s'agit d'une
obligation qui serait vrai simpblement
jugée inconstitutionnelle car
constituant une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté
d'entreprendre la seconde obligation
elle porte sur l'information du du
consommateur et ça je vous soutiens sur
la deuxième obligation j'y reviendrai
l'information du consommateur je pense
là qu'on peut faire beaucoup et
d'ailleurs c'est un de nos levier
d'action mais elle ne peut néanmoins pas
faire l'objet du type de sanction que
vous prévoyez et là là-dessus je
reviendrai très précisément et la
troisème obligation ensuite que vous
proposez elle est au cœur de la
procédure en cours devant la Commission
européenne qui concerne Google car c'est
en elle est en réalité déjà couverte par
le droit de la concurrence qu'il soit
national ou européen d'ailleurs il vous
aura pas échappé que la procédure
européenne que que j'évoqué elle vient
donc de franchir cette nouvelle étape
importante que nous réclamions par la
notification des des grifs qui qui s'est
faite hier et elle porte sur les
conditions de traitement de de ses
propres services dans les résultats
affichés par son moteur de recherche et
donc l'ouverture d'une d'une phase
contentieuse va permettre d'avancer ça
je pense que c'est un point important je
déplore comme vous les délai mais c'est
un outil significatif et la 4ème
obligation il me semble qu'elle confond
quant à elle de sujets le moteur de
recherche il fait de fournir aussi des
systèmes logiciels pour les terminaux
parce que c'est le cas de Google avec
Android mais alors
ce n'est plus le moteur de recherche
qu'il faut encadrer mais les systèmes
logiciels de terminaux ce qui montre que
le sujet est bien plus large que le seul
objet de votre amendement et qu'il faut
l'appréhender à travers d'une part la
politique de concurrence européenne mais
aussi à travers une approche beaucoup
plus englobante qui traitera aussi du
sujet des logiciels pour terminaux
qu'onattrape pas avec votre amendement
et donc on est déjà en retard on est
déjà en retard par rapport à ce que
Google a fait alors ça m'amène au
deuxième volet de de de votre amendement
qui est le régime de contrôle et de
sanction et là vous proposez de confier
à l'ARCEP ce rôle alors en premier lieu
moi je je ne pense pas qu'il soit
souhaitable de confier un régulateur
dont la compétence est circonscrite au
Télécom une compétence général je je
reprends votre terme de supervision des
marchés de l'économie numérique parce
que le périmètre même de ce marché il
est évolutif il est en train d'évoluer
et il est nettement au-delà des des
compétences de il est même largement on
le voit bien à travers la compétence
même de la Commission sur ces sujets
est-ce que c'est la DG sectorienne qui s
cisite de ce sujet non c'est la
commissaire en charge de la concurrence
et donc ça n'est pas l'Arcep le bon
levier je je veux pas ici m'exposer à
des reproches nveau pour dire que
l'Autorité de la concurrence aurait sans
doute à voir mais très honnêtement par
rapport au critères que vous pointez et
d'ailleurs matériellement c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure vous qualifiez
l'effet structurant sur l'économie qui
est une notion de droit de la
concurrence pas une notion du droit des
télécom de l'arcepp et donc là vous avez
un décalage parce que vous utilisez une
base juridique qui est celle du droit de
la concurrence pour fonder ensuite motif
et vous demandez à un régulateur
sectoriel de l'appliquer ça c'est mon
premier problème en second lieu l'arcepp
se verrait alors doté d'un pouvoir de
sanction des moteurs de recherche et
elle tient aujourd'hui l'essentiel de
son pouvoir de sanction de télécom du
cadre réglementaire européen qui ne les
lui donne pas et qui ne les lui donnera
pas et donc je pense que ce faisant vous
avez un risque fort en plus avoir un
régime inopérant sur ce sujet-là plus
globalement l'amendement échappe à la
logique sur laquelle se sont fondé les
différentes régulations sectorielle qui
a été la construction don qui permet
justement de déroger à la liberté
d'entreprendre parce que c'est là qu'on
veut mettre un coin aujourd'hui qui est
l'identification au niveau européen d'un
marché pour lequel les remèdes
concurrentiels ne permettent pas
d'établir des conditions satisfaisantes
de marché et et la mise en place d'un
cadre réglementaire ad hoc la
détermination au niveau national des
remèdes et leviers d'intervention ex
santé permettant d'assurer un
encadrement structurel ou comportemental
des entreprises en cause c'est cette
base je reprenais les textes qui
justifie que nous que nous poussons pour
construire en Europe s'agissant des
plateformes numériques mais qui suppose
de continuer la démarche par le la
concurrence et qui suppose de de
construire cette stratégie numérique
cette feuille de route numérique qui
n'existe pas dont les bases ont été
posées par le sommet européen de
l'automne 2013 en posant le principe des
plateformes numérique des places de
marché des systèmes d'exploitation mais
dont il faut maintenant construire les
éléments de droit alors vous l'avez bien
compris je comprends et je souscrit à
votre objectif mais je pense vraiment
que la méthode n'est pas la bonne pour
toutes les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer à la fois parce qu'elle est
défaillante et donc concrètement ce sera
inopérant ce sera inopérant et en plus
elle est en décalage j'ajoute à ça si
maintenant on se place du point de vue
de l'opérateur que vous voulez réguler
Google mais Google à travers vos
finalement votre
accroche vous voudriez c'est un peu
aussi l'objet de votre sous-amendement
Google n'est pas en
France Google n'a que sa régie
publicitaire enfin n'a qu'une régie
publicitaire française et n'a même pas
de moteur de recherche en tant que tel
situé en France et donc ces dispositions
à cet égard se heurterit à ses limites
et elle se heurterait aussi au droit
européens qui ne manquera pas d'y voir
une mesure contraire au principe de l'
prestation au sein de l'Union européenne
et donc le paradoxe même c'est qu'on
serait prêt à contrepiier alors
néanmoins que faire je pense qu'il faut
continuer avec vigueur le débat que nous
avons aujourd'hui montre la sensibilité
du sujet il faut le porter fort le
porter médiatiquement
l'accompagner montrer la préoccupation
de la Haute Assemblée celle du
gouvernement que je veux ici réaffirmer
pour aller en ce sens et aller plus vite
je crois que honnêtement la commissaire
westager l'a compris elle a pris toutes
ses responsabilités sur ce dossier
depuis le début il n'était pas
totalement manché comme il est sorti
hier et je dois ici lui rendre hommage
elle a pris ses responsabilités moi dès
ma première rencontre avec elle elle
avait 2 jours à son poste elle s'est
engagée à à vraiment prendre en compte
nos revendications sur ce sujet elle
s'est engagé à défendre les intérêts de
nos opérateurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'opérateurs français et elle a tenu ses
engagements je tiens ici à le dire il
faut lui rendre hommage et donc c'est
qu'on continue à aller en ce sens que on
puisse éventuellement avoir des éléments
de traduction nationale moi je suis prêt
à avancer dans la direction que vous
ouvrez aujourd'hui je pense que
l'amendement ne convient pas mais je
suis prêt à ce qu'on continue à
travailler en ce sens il y a une voix
qui me semble plus solide et qui
peut-être expertisé c'est la meilleure
protection des droits des utilisateurs
français et finalement moi c'est
là-dessus que je voulais conclure parce
que la bonne accroche pour réguler les
opérateurs les plateformes elle est au
niveau européen elle est au niveau
européen on n pas la bonne accroche
français parce que les acteurs ne sont
pas là et parce que on n pas le levier
par contre la bonne approche que nous
devons avoir voir pour y compris
d'ailleurs continuer à la porter au
niveau européen elle est par les
utilisateurs c'est d'ailleurs comme ça
qu'on les attrapera parce que on aura
même au niveau européen une un plafond
de verre à notre raisonnement qui est
que ils sont à Mountain View ceux dont
on parle ils sont même pas à Bruxelles
ou à Berlin ou à Londres bon et donc sur
ce sujet je pense qu'il faut qu'on
avance beaucoup plus vite beaucoup plus
fort sur le droit des utilisateurs on a
une base aujourd'hui qui existe dans la
loi du 17 mars 2014 relative à la
consommation qui au chapitre 1er du
titre 1 du livre 1er du Code de la
Consommation dans sa rédaction résultant
de l'article 6 précisément de sa loi a
inséré un article L 1111-5 réglementant
les comparateurs de prix qui ont leur
siège en France je vais pas vous en
faire lecture mais je vous renvoie à cet
article qui nous donne une base et sur
cette voie qui consiste non pas à
réguler la
plateforme ce qui ressort comme je le
dis ce qui du ressort de de l'Union
européenne je reviens pas sur
l'argumentation que j'ai fait mais a
donné des droits aux individus qu'il
puissent faire valoir sur cette base moi
je pense qu'il faut qu'on avance d'abord
en lançant des contrôles ce qu'on a
commencé à faire c'est sur cette base
aussi que j'ai pu saisir l'autorité de
la concurrence et en travaillant sur une
amélioration du cadre législatif et
essayer d'aller plus loin donc moi je
m'engage puisque nous aurons l'occasion
de nous revoir à la fois à l'Assemblée
et et ici à la continuation de ce texte
mais pour essayer de voir si de manière
très concrète on peut aller plus loin
sur la partie de défense des droits des
utilisateurs mais je pense que les les
voix et moyens qui sont utilisés par
votre amendement comme je l'ai dit ne
sont pas les bonnes en opportunités et
en droit pour avancer dans le sens que
vous souhaiter voilà l'explication que
je voulais faire à cette demande de
retrait en espérant qu'elles vous auront
convaincu mais en même temps en
m'engageant à ce que sur la partie droit
des utilisateurs on puisse
avancer merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues il est
12h50 tendez la séance doit être
suspendue à 13h j'ai un certain nombre
de de dem d'explication de vote donc où
nous sommes très succins ou je seraai
obligé d'interrompre au milieu de la
discussion de cet article additionnel à
13h voilà alors je commence par Madame
brick qui m'a demandé la parole en
premier monsieur le Président je crois
que je veux bien prendre la parole mais
le ministre a fait des
propositions il a
argumenter je pense qu'on veut tous
aboutir à associer le moteur de
recherche des produits
d'application c'est ça l'objectif et il
est même partagé je pense par
l'Autorité de la concurrence européenne
TFC la commission la commissaire
européenne a repris un dossier qui était
complètement calminé par l'ancienne
Commission almounia ne s'était pas
occupé de cette affaire esttait-ce
volontaire ou pas mais elle elle a agi
euh moi je pense que il faudrait que
madame la présidente de la commission
culture nous disent ce qu'elle répond à
l'argumentation du ministre et aux
propositions de travail parce que
l'objectif euh des deux grands
régulateurs européens États-Unis c'est à
terme d'aboutir à la neutralité des
plateformes ce qui n'est pas le cas à
l'heure actuelle c'est clair que Google
écrase la concurrence moi je connais
bien un secteur c'est celui du voyage et
le voyage c'est plus de la moitié par
internet donc à partir de là comme
Google a son propre service de voyage
c'est le mélange moteur de recherche et
cetera donc ce que je voudrais quand
même dire aussi c'est qu'on dispose en
France d'une très belle pépite il faut
qu'elle puisse grandir c'est un N
problème et il faut qu'elle puisse
devenir un grand groupe pour demain et
dans le cadre du travail avec les
Allemands il faut aussi faire en sorte
qu'on est un champion européen parce
qu'on a pris trop de retard là-dessus
c'est le sujet donc moi je je voudrais
savoir ce que fait madame la Présidente
parce que j'ai considéré que son
amendement c'était un signal que la
France voulait donner par rapport à ces
objectifs que nous partageons tous mais
c'est clair qu'on est dans le droit
européen et il se trouve que hier soir
la commissaire Vestager a agi pour la
première fois
donc comment dire Google a 2 mois pour
répondre mais je pense que il y a une
volonté politique au niveau européen
maintenant de régler ce problème et
c'est clair qu'il y a une volonté
politique française et c'est ce que vous
vouliez dire par votre amendement donc
maintenant j'attends de savoir ce que
madame la Présidente répond au
ministre monsieur
biset merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez
totalement raison de considérer que le
bon niveau d'intervention est le niveau
européen c'est vrai mais que la réaction
de la Commission elle est toute récente
vous savez le jugement que je porte sur
l'autorité de la concurrence tant
communautaire que ses déclinaisons
nationales et il est vrai que l'ancien
commissaire n'avait pas sur ce domaineel
comme sur beaucoup d'autres domaines une
vision communautaire une vision
européenne voire une vision mondiale
d'un différ d'un certain nombre de de de
sujets je peux vous dire ayant eu
l'opportunité de rencontrer le président
Junker avec le président Larcher ayant
vu ensuite très récemment le commissaire
tinger ça fait partie des dossiers phar
des premiers dossiers de la Commission
européenne ceci étant cet amendement est
fondamental moi j'y ai adhéré j'aiai
Cigné il lance le débat j'ai bien
entendu vos vos vos réponses mais il est
bien clair que il est terriblement
important que nous puissions récupérer
la gouvernance européenne de l'Internet
parce que c'est vrai que l'Europe ne
peut pas être une colonie numérique d'un
certain nombre nbre d'opérateurs et
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure Catherine
main desci c'est vrai que les
algorithmes ne sont ni objectifs ni
infaillible ils sont tout simplement le
bras armé d'un certain nombre
d'opérateurs et par hasard enfin pas
tout à fait par hasard la plupart des
opérateurs sont précisément des
opérateurs américains je regrette que
compte tenu si vous voulez de
l'enseignement en mathématique
fondamental de la place de Paris on
parle même de l'École de Paris je puis
souligner que les chercheurs et
ingénieurs français sont
particulièrement appréciés dans le monde
informatique et donc il nous manque à
gravir un deuxième échelon c'est de se
réapproprier précisément la la
gouvernance de l'Internet donc on verra
comment on peut raisonner sur ce sujet
moi je prends note de votre volonté de
mettre votre ministère au service de la
réflexion pour trouver une solution mais
il est bien évident qu'elle sera de
dimension européenne
OK
bien merci monsieur le Président bien
que n'étant pas supportable de
l'Olympique de Marseille je dirais
droite au
but nous
allons si la si l'amendement est
maintenu ce que nous souhaitons nous le
voterons donc c'estàdire que Monsieur le
Ministre votre prévision de d'un vote de
cet amendement serait à l'unanimité
voilà c'est notre souhait alors parce
qu'il a le mérite d'abord il est
pertinent il est pertinent et c'est bien
que ce sujet arrive dans la sphère
politique il est essentiel que la sphère
politique s'empare de ces sujets ne sans
nier l'importance de l'économique mais
il a bien été démontré ces dernières
années ces derniers mois que la
problématique des grands groupes a
bousculé considérablement la sphère
économique en France en Europe et dans
le monde et que donc le politique avec
un grand pai doit s'emparer de ce sujet
c'est une évidence les Américains le
font les Britanniques le font
souvenez-vous de ces audition musclé au
Parlement britannique avec Margaret HCH
qui interrogait les représentants de
Starbucks Google et compagnie ça sec
couit un peu et c'était ça faisait un
peu de bien après ça ne règle pas tout
le problème mais en tout cas c'est un
vrai sujet et j'ajouterai volontiers
notre collègue Jean biset vient
d'ajouter un deuxième volet avec
l'aspect gouvernance et Internet
j'appuie tout à fait j'ajoute volontiers
un troème volet le volet fiscal dont on
peut pas faire abstraction quand même et
au sein de l'Europe se sont posé des
questions ces derniers temps je pense
évidemement à l'affaire luxlex où des
réscrits fiscaux très avantageux ont été
accordés par l'un de nos partenaires
historique de l'Union européenne à des
grands groupes dont les grands groupes
de l'Internet il y a de vraies questions
qui se posent le problème devient donc
dans la sphère politique aujourd'hui et
il faut s'en féliciter rappelons quand
même que le fabricant de nos compagnons
inséparables que sont devenus nos
téléphones intelligents aujourd'hui P 2
% d'impôt c'est une vraie question il a
que les États qui peuvent lever l'impôt
pour défendre l'intérêt général et
développer une société un peu plus
humaine ou un peu moins inhumaine donc
c'est un vrai sujet donc cet amendement
est pertinent s'il est maintenu nous le
voterons bien volontiers je
Donis on est effectivement sur un débat
très très très important quand on
regarde l'impact que peut avoir la
position dominante de Google sur
l'économie il y a certes le problème du
moteur de recherche mais il y a derrière
toute je dire c'est au-delà même au-delà
des applications qui sont liées c'est la
recherche européenne dans le domaine du
numérique qui est en jeu nous voyons
tuer dans l'œuf aujourd'hui des pans
entiers de l'innovation dans le domaine
du numérique lié à cette position
dominante je le vois sur mon département
avec la technopole de sopia an
antipolice où nous avons une difficulté
objective de déc de de développement
des startups dans ce domaines bien à
partir de là Monsieur le Ministre votre
réponse est
implacable à la fois de rigueur et de
cohérence sur le domaine du droit et
vous avez poser la question essentielle
que faire parce que nous ne pouvons pas
rester en la matière les bras ballants
on constate une évolution je note même
que le Sénat
américain a lancé une enquête sur
l'échec de la régulation y compris par
rapport à à
Google il me paraît important que nous
puissions adopter cependant cet
amendement au-delà de ces imperfections
réelles qui ont été démontrées mais que
nous puissions simultanément répondre à
la demande du ministre qui est qu'il y
ait un travail qui soit effectué
de façon à ce que au-delà dans cette
question de la navette nous ayons marqué
déjà aujourd'hui un espace et une
volonté et qu'à travers cet acte fort
que nous produisons aujourd'hui au Sénat
en tant que parlementaire je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce genre de démarche mais vu
l'importance du sujet je suis prêt
à plier que nous puissions avoir une
réponse qui soit elle juridiquement
beaucoup mieux construite et en liaison
avec le gouvernement que nous puissions
trouver la réponse la plus adéquate et
adaptée en l'état c'est ce qui
m'apparaît j'allais dire la moins
mauvaise solution par rapport à une
situation extrêmement préoccupante pour
l'avenir de la recherche européenne en
matière de
numérique monsieur
le monsieur monieur le président
monsieur le ministre oui le sujet que
nous traitons est de dimension
européenne on en est tous convaincus oui
il faut soutenir et encourager tant que
faire se peut la création d'un groupe
puissant en Europe international qui
puisse rétablir une forme de concurrence
loyale avec les grands opérateurs
américains oui nous constitu nous
constatons une porte ouverte une
ouverture de la Commission européenne
depuis depuis hier
mais n'oublions pas et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je souhaite que madame la
Présidente de la Commission la culture
maintienne son amendement n'oublions pas
que si la doctrine européenne avance
c'est parfois sous le coup de boutoir de
nos amendements de nos résolutions de
nos PPL et que aujourd'hui même si cet
amendement est voué à
cheminer à faire progresser les choses
sans aboutir immédiatement je pense
qu'il faut le maintenir parce que c'est
encore un signal supplémentaire vers la
Commission européenne merci Monsieur
Colomba constatons que les États-Unis
ont plus d'activités enfin défendent
mieux leurs intérêts que que nous
constatons que jusqu'à présent la
Commission européenne a mis autant
d'activités et d'entrains à ouvrir nos
frontières à la concurrence des
États-Unis qui a se constitué qui a
constitué l'Europe en tant que puissance
autonome
donc bon autrefois on disait quand on
veut enterrer une une question on nomme
une commission là on fait du droit il
faudrait peut-être faire aussi autre
chose que du droit on n pas qu'un
problème de droit on n pas qu'un
problème de technique tout le monde l'a
dit c'est un problème politique bon
donc ma
fois ce message qu'on envoie que
deviendra-t-il on nen sait rien ce
message politique est une façon de dire
à au commissari au commissaire européen
dire à l'Europe que nous en avons assez
de ce qui se passe et qu'il faudrait
peut-être agir donc il faut le prendre
il faut le prendre comme ça et c'est une
façon de dire encore une fois que il
faut véritablement agir alors est-ce que
c'est la bonne méthode pas la bonne
méthode mais ce message il n'est pas du
tout à noodin et puis pour une fois pour
une fois qu'on peut apporter notre
concours soutenir la Commission
européenne en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne je ne veux pas manquer ce
plaisir merci bien cher collègue il est
13h donc où nous sommes capables dans
les 5 minutes de conclure ou alors de le
débat sera sur cet amendement là sera
reporté après les questions au
Gouvernement alors madame maourin de sa
et après vous soit nous votons soit
c'est reporté cet après-midi non mais
Madame B de demande la
parole
oui ben je voulais tout simplement
prendre la parole pour dire que je
maintenais cet amendement j'ai d'abord
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention la
réaction de mes collègues et leur point
de vue j'ai conscience monsieur le
ministre que cet amendement n'est
peut-être pas parfait mais nous avons
encore du temps pour l'améliorer
ensemble d'ici la la
CMP je crois que c'est un travail
collectif d'ailleurs c'était un travail
collectif au Sénat cette proposition
elle n'arrive pas par hasard c'est 4 ans
de travail au sein de la commission des
affaires européennes au sein d'une
mission commune d'information où tous
les collègues de l'ensemble des
commissions et des groupes politiques
différents ont participé toujours dans
une belle unanimité quant au diagnostic
et aux propositions à à formuler bien
entendu c'est au niveau européen nous
l'avons dit au Sénat depuis des années
et nous savons que ce n'est pas le seul
chantier d'ailleurs à mener c'est aussi
euh une démarche offensive de la
régulation de l'écosystème numérique
pour un meilleur partage de la valeur
ajoutée en levant en jouant à la fois
sur le levier de la fiscalité mais mais
aussi celui de la juste concurrence
c'est aussi exiger un régime euh
réaliste de protection de nos données
personnel le le lobbying outreAtlantique
fait que aujourd'hui le Règlement sur
les données qui étaient sur le point
d'aboutir n'est toujours pas adopté or
les données personnelles c'est l'or noir
du numérique c'est ce qui justement
alimente la machine de guerre si je puis
dire donc ça c'est encore un chantier
l'éducation la formation au numérique
puis une politique industrielle
extrêmement puissante pour faire émerger
des champions européen tout cela nous
l'avons dit Monsieur le Ministre tout ça
on souhaite pouvoir le pousser continuer
à travailler mais on constate aussi que
toutes ces années les procédures
européennes sont extrêmement lentes
qu'est-ce qui nous dit que
là la les conclusions de de l'enquête il
y a eu bien sûr la communication des
grief combien de temps ça va prendre
encore et on connaît aussi l'habilité du
lobing de de Google auprès des autorités
bruxelloises pour tenter des
négociations
endormir un petit peu les uns et les
autres autour de belles promesses et on
sait que
ça échoué donc je dis il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir et pousser pousser
être un marche pied par cet amendement
c'est un marchepied pour notre
participation au débats
européens ça me semble tout à fait
essentiel et je trouve que rester là les
bras ballants aujourd'hui quand tant
d'entreprises nous signalent leurs
difficultés disent carrément maintenant
que les moteurs de recher structure en
droit de vie ou de mort sur leur propre
activité c'est au détriment bien sûr de
la liberté de commercer nos grandes
libertés la liberté de choix du du
consommateur euh donc je pense qu'il y a
urgence à à agir dans dans ce domaine
euh alors je voulais juste répondre à à
deux trois points qui ont été évoqués on
me dit que il y aurait un problème de
constitutionnalité par rapport à la
politique européenne de de concurrence
moi je note que l'article 102 du TF UE
interdit l'exploitation abusive d'une
position dominante par une entreprise je
cite le droit européen de la concurrence
ne sanctionne pas les positions
dominantes en tant que tel mais
seulement les abus donc c'est bien les
abus dont il s'agit une position
dominante lorsqu'une entreprise peut
mener la politique et dire sans se
préoccuper de celle de ses concurrents
sur ce marché voilà la définition donc
on est je pense tout à fait dans la
droite ligne je ne vois pas ce qui nous
empêche à la fois de pousser des
décisions ni européen et euh inscrire ce
type de disposition dans notre droit euh
positif et agir au niveau national en
tout cas les acteurs de l'économie
numérique ont besoin d'un signe fort ça
trop duré et nous sommes peut-être en
passe d'être dans une phase irréversible
si très rapidement nous ne sommes pas
capable de prendre les mesures qui
permettent d'inverser la tendance à
savoir on construit ce marché unique
numérique pour en être les acteurs les
bénéficières et pas les simples
consommateurs or pour l'instant c'est ce
vers quoi on veut nous entraîner et on
sait encore une fois que les procédures
sont tellement long qui s'écoule
tellement de de temps que pendant ce
temps-là ce sont des emplois qui
disparaissent ce sont des entreprises
qui dis disparaissent donc on doit bien
sûr agir voilà j'aurais encore min de
choses à dire pour répondre aux
arguments des uns et des autres mais je
vois l'heure qui tourne tout ça pour
vous dire que le travail n'est pas
terminé l'amendement de de Monsieur
assouine voà voilà il est pas
communautaire c'est notre président de
la commission des affaires européennes
le souligne et mais je je comprends quel
est l'état d'esprit de David la souigne
qui veut souligner par là que c'est un
soutien fort à nos entreprises aussi
qu'il faut apporter voilà merci monsieur
le Président merci madame la Présidente
je vais donc passer au vote en mettant
au voix le sous-amendement
1792 avec un avis de défavo
pardon mais vraiment une phrase monsieur
assouine qu'une phrase non je ne dis pas
plus qu'une phrase vous dites que vous
êtes d'accord mais que c'est pas le
droit européen or vous avez dit pour
défondreamendement et le vôtre et je
suis d'accord avec cette démarche quand
le ministre vous dit dit que ce n'est
pas conforme au droitopérin le votre
vous dites il faut d'abord faire une
manifestation de volonté politique bien
donc je vous demande de faire la même
manifestation de volonté politique pour
que dans les trois parce que le paradoxe
c'est que si on propose les trois et
qu'il y a aucun Français ça sera la même
chose pour nous donc dans les trois on
propose un français c'est tout et après
on verra mais c'est la manifestation
politique qu'il faut affirmer je mets
donc au voix le sous-amendement
1792 qui est pour
alors 2 3 4 qui est contre
is écoutez il y a doute hein bon alors
qui est pour nous sommes au
sous-amendement
1792 que ceux qui veulent bien que ceux
qui sont pour se
lèvent nous faisons un assis debout sur
le
1792 ceux qui sont pour se lèvent voilà
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 9 ah alors 10 12 13 14
14 bien que ceux qui sont contre se
lèvent 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 bon il est adopté
et nous passons à l'amendement
995 rectifié bis de madame la Présidente
Mourin de sali euh euh qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
il est adopté
bien voilà pour les débats des sénateurs
lors de cette première lecture du projet
de loi Macron projet de loi croissance
activité égalité des chances économiques
à l'époque vous l'avez entendu les
sénateurs avaient donc adopté ce
dispositif Antig Google qui obligé le
fameux géant américain à afficher sur sa
page d'accueil trois liens vers des
moteurs de recherche différent vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site publicena.fr
très bonne journée sur la chaîes
par je propose
que toute
personne majeure en phase avancée ou
terminale incurable d'une maladie
provoquant une souffrance physique
psychique insupportable et qui ne peut
plus être apaisé puisse demander dans
des conditions précises et sous contrôle
de plusieurs médecins à bénéficier d'une
assistance médicale pour vivre sa vie
dans la dignité jusqu'à la fin
après le mariage pour tous c'est l'une
des réformes de société sur laquelle on
attendait François Hollande le droit à
une aide active à mourir en proposant
une assistance médicale pour vivre sa
vie dans la dignité jusqu'à la fin le
candidat Hollande a délibérément choisi
une formulation ambigue où jamais il ne
prononce le mot
euthanasie des mots à la loi le
président avance avec prudence
après 2 ans de concertation nationale il
confie la rédaction d'une proposition de
loi à deux députés Alain clè et Jean
Leonetti une proposition de loi
consensuelle qui reprend et précise la
première loi Leonetti de 2005 sans aller
jusqu'à
l'euthanasie selon un sondage pourtant
90 % des Français ils sont favorables
pour les personnes en fin de vie ce
nouveau texte répond-til vraiment aux
attentes des Français va-t-il assez loin
de la promesse de campagne à la loi le
consensus sera difficile à
trouver pourquoi un nouveau texte et
bien parce que malheureusement dans la
pratique on constate encore qu'on meurt
mal en France on meurt mal avec deux
revendications légitimes de nos
concitoyens c'est je ne suis pas entendu
en fin de vie et on continue à souffrir
dans les derniers jours les dernières
heures de la
vie bonjour
bONJ comment ça va ce matin et ben ce
matin ça va très bien ouais les douleurs
ici
là vous les sentez un petit peu quand
même à 78 ans
c'est la deuxième fois qu'Angel est en
soin palliatif au CHU de
Montpellier atteinte d'un cancer
incurable elle sait sa mort proche son
seul souhait finir ses jours sans
souffrir Mo ma propre mort je l'envie je
je sais que je Mouri mais je veux pas
mourir en souffrant voilà je sais que je
vais mourir un de ses jours parce que ça
ça est au point où on est palliatif pour
la douleur et tout ça par qu'il y a pas
d'autre chose grand chose à faire mais
on n pas la souffrance moi je comprends
les gens quand ils souffrent trop vite
se jettent sous le train parce que c'est
des souffrance qu'on peut pas tenir
quand on fait les soins palliatifs après
au contraire ça ça soulage ça ça guérit
pas mais ça enlève la douleur moi c'est
ce que je veux je veux
mourir sans souffrir
voilà pour soulager les souffrances dans
ce centre de soins palliatif on utilise
des techniques à la pointe comme la
sédation une sorte d'anesthésie plus ou
moins profonde pour apaiser le patient
cette technique sédation c'est quand on
est en échec effectivement sur un
symptôme particulièrement insupportable
pour le patient donc
avec certains médicaments enfin
notamment leamidazolan on l'utilise pour
entraîner un sommeil d'une profondeur
qui va dépendre du patient des patients
qui préfèent é un petit peu éveillé
d'autres qui ne veulent pas être du tout
réveillés donc ça on adapte la dose et
qu'on peut faire de manière transitoire
par exemple pour un symptôme comme le
dispné qui peut être parfois
transitoire ou pour de manière on peut
également faire cette sititation de
manière continue si le patient
effectivement ne désire plus du tout
être révé la loi de 2015 veut
démocratiser la sédation profonde et
continue c'est-à-dire l'endormissement
profond du patient dont la mort est
imminente pour lui éviter de souffrir
lors de ces dernières
heures ce qu' le on veut vraiment c'est
endormir le patient pour pas qu'il qu'il
subisse ce qu'il est en train de vivre
mais on ne veut pas précipiter sa mort
simplement il faut qu'il soit quand même
un peu plus serein par rapport à ce
queil est en train de vivre on met des
fois des sédation comme ça sur des
choses cataclysmiques on voit et ça on a
on a eu à le faire il y a pas très
longtemps un patient qui s'est vidé de
son sang euh et qui le voyait et qui
était conscient et c'était terrible et
bon donc là on l'a endormi et il est
parti non pas de notre endormissement
mais du fait qu'il était en train de se
vider sur d'une hémorragie sur lequelle
on pouvait pas intervenir si vous
voulez si dans ce genre d'unité
spécialisée les médecins maîtrisent
cette technique ce n'est pas le cas dans
d'autres services hospitaliers comme aux
urgences ou dans les services
d'oncologie ù le taux de mortalité est
élevé la sédation profonde est continue
y est peu utilisé l'objectif de la loi
est donc de la
généraliser ce droit qu'on appelle le
droit à la sédation en phase terminale
est un droit qui paraît légitime
aujourd'hui c'est un devoir des médecins
de le mettre en place ça n'est pas le
cas malheureusement dans 15 à 20 % des
cas et bien il faut que ça devienne un
droit et peut-être que la vraie
modification de la loi
c'est de dire avant c'était un devoir de
la société et un devoir des du corps
médical et des soignants de faire en
sorte qu'on ne souffre pas en fin de vie
et bien désormais ça devient un droit du
malade de ne pas souffrir lorsque la
mort approche et que les médicaments
habituel n'arrive pas à calmer la
souffrance la nouvelle loi précise les
cas où cette sédation profonde et
continue doit
s'appliquer premier cas le patient est
conscient il est atteint d'un infection
grave et incurable son pronostic vital
est engagé et l'arrêt des traitements va
provoquer sa mort à court
terme autre possibilité le patient est
inconscient pour éviter l'acharnement
thérapeutique le médecin décide
d'arrêter les traitements il peut dans
ce cas aussi demander une sédation
profonde et
continue en encadrant la sédation
profonde et continue les auteurs de la
loi voulaient être
consensuel mais au Sénat cette
proposition va cristalliser les
oppositions autour de la question de
l'euthanasie tris camp vont s'affronter
il y a d'un côté les rapporteurs de la
proposition du texte et le gouvernement
ils vont soutenir l'idée d'une sédation
profonde et continue ce texte est ce est
pour ceux qui vont mourir pas pour ceux
qui veulent mourir ce qui élimine très
clairement le le débat sur l'euthanasie
et le suicide assisté non pas que ce
débat ne soit pas important voire
capital mais quelque part ce n'était pas
l'esprit de la loi sur laquelle nous
discutions d'autres une partie des
sénateurs républicains s'oppose à toute
évolution juridique pour le texte va
trop loin en inscrivant la sédation
profonde et continue dans la loi le
législateur proposerait en réalité une
euthanasie
déguisée la sédation profonde continue
jusqu'au décès vous voyez bien on liait
la sédation et le décès et là ça nous a
apparu pas pour moi seulement mais pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous comme
quelque chose qui sortait du dispositif
consensuel de la loi Leonetti et qu'il y
ait le décès à l'acte de sédation donc
on engageait on
s'engageait sur dans
l'engrenage sur le chemin du suicide
assisté et
l'ethanasie enfin il y a les sénateurs
qui estiment que cette sédation profonde
et continue n'est pas suffisante ils
veulent inscrire dans la loi le droit à
l'euthanasie nous voulions répondre à
deux demandes différentes qui sont de de
nature différentes d'une part le droit à
un suicide médicalement assisteré
c'est-à-dire que on abrège la fin de vie
un peu avant le terme qui est imminent
et puis donc c'est le suicide assisteré
et puis d'autres part il y a des
personnes qui réclament lorsqu'elles
sont dans un état désespéré la
possibilité d'une
euthanasie premier affrontement en
séance autour de l'article 3 sur la
sédation profonde et
continue les opposants à cette pratique
lance l'ofensif contre les rapporteurs
du texte depuis le départ un certain
nombre d'entre nous pensons que la loi
les se suisait à elle-même et que et que
la loi actuelle qui est pour certains
prolongement ou un éclairage n'est pas
un prolongement ou un éclairage c'est
une rupture il est incontestable que cet
article 3 et la porte ouverte à une
euthanasie que ne voulez pas dénommer
comme t
les sénateurs proposent d'enlever du
texte l'expression continue jusqu'au
décès pour éviter tout amalgame avec
l'euthanasie pour Alain Milon le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales qui est aussi médecin c'est un
coup porté au principe même de la loi
bon cette proposition de loi ne ne tue
pas on n'est pas là pour tuer on n'est
pas là pour faire d'euthanasie on est là
pour accompagner des malades en fin de
vie alors
la proposition que que nous fait notre
collègue de Lège sur le fait de mettre
une sédation profonde et de supprimer
continue jusqu'au décès ok pourquoi pas
ça veut dire que la sédation n'est pas
continue elle si elle n'est pas continue
elle est discontinue et si elle est
discontinue ça veut dire qu'on doit
l'arrêter de temps en temps pourquoi
continue plaçons-nous quand même dans la
vraie vie si j'ose dire comment imaginer
que chez ces patients qui souffrent
atrocement on va interrompre la sédation
pour dialoguer avec eux sur
l'opportunité de quoi de continuer c'est
impensable et vraiment ceux qui ont
porté cet amendement sont très éloignés
de de la vraie vie c'est le cas de le
dire je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 59 rectifié qui est
pour l'amendement est
adopté une partie des républicains
obtient gain de cause le mot continue
est retiré du texte la séance est
suspendue dans les couloirs les esprits
s'échauffent entre les deux camps je su
pas content pas cont
CEUB y aux qui
sont
pré ça a été disons de manière un peu
habile sans doute par certains de
vouloir faire comprendre que la sédation
profonde et continue était très proche
de l'euthanasie alors ça n'est pas vrai
puisque l'euthanasie elle est faite à un
moment avant qu'on soit dans ces
situations là c'estàdire avant que la
personne soit vraiment en fin de vie
c'està-dire avec une espérance de vie à
court terme et ne supportant plus les
souffrances qu'elle subit donc ce n'est
pas du tout une euthanasie c'est
simplement une possibilité d'aider à
mourir sans avoir les
souffrances l'autre offensive contre le
texte viendra cette fois des
proethanasies
i sénateur de toute tendance politique
réuni autour de Jean-Luc Roméo président
de laadmd une association proethanasie
convoque la presse il y a dans chaque
groupe des parlementaires qui ont déposé
des amendements allant dans le sens de
ce que souhaite de ce que souhaite la
DMD c'est-à-dire qu'il y a enfin une loi
qui permette à chacun de choisir c'est
pas une loi spécialement pour leutanasie
une loi qui permette de comment dire de
choisir il compte inscrire dans le texte
un droit à une aide active à
mourir bah c'est important justement que
certains sénateurs et de toute tendance
c'est ça qui était important puissent
dire que eux ils souhaitaent clairement
qu'on aille à la légalisation de
l'euthanasie du f d'assister comme les
Français le le le demande dans tous les
sondages depuis 20 ou 30
ans le soir Mme même en séance les h
sénateurs déposent tous un amendement
pour légaliser
l'euthanasie cet amendement propose
d'instaurer un droit à bénéficier d'une
véritable aide active pour mourir pour
les personnes majeures il répond à une
très forte demande de la population il
vise à instaurer l'assistance
médicalisée active à mourir dans des
conditions strictes chacun doit se voir
ainsi reconnaître le droit d'aborder sa
fin de vie dans le respect des principes
de liberté d'égalité
fraternité des amendements rejetés mais
l'objectif est atteint le débat sur
l'eutanasie a été mis sur la
table nous voulions poser ce débat
c'est-à-dire d'une loi qui irait plus
loin donc l'idée était d'expliquer
pourquoi cette loi nous semblait trop
timide et pourquoi nous voulions aller
plus loin et pourquoi du coup nous avons
tous déposé un amendement très très
voisin pour essayer d'avancer alors
l'ambiguïé qu'il faudrait lever c'est
que ce texte n'était pas fait pour ceux
qui sont en fin de vie et et qui veulent
mourir ce texte a été fait pour les
malades en fin de vie qui vont mourir
donc évidemment ce texte ne recouvrait
que très imparfaitement les demandes que
nous
avions l'autre point de clivage du texte
ce sont les directives anticipées un
document où l'on inscrit ce que l'on
souhaite pour sa fin de vie
edit a écrit les siennes les bénévoles
au centre d'écoute de l'ADMD
l'association au droit à mourir dans la
dignité compte tenu de mon
âge je refuse toute
réanimation alimentation forcée
artificielle lorsque la mort paraît
inévitable mettre sur papier ce qu'elle
veut pour sa fin de vie une évidence
pour elle après la mort d'une de ses
amis en 1987 j'ai assisté à la mort
terrifiante d'une amie qui avait une
sclérose latérale amotrophique la
maladie de Charco et qui mourait dans
des conditions d'étouffementes qui n'en
finissait plus j'ai appeler le docteur
c'était un dimanche on a fait venir SOS
médecin et j'ai dit au médecin écoutez
elle est en fin de vie regardez est en
train de mourir en c'est tout fort il me
dit oui elle va mourir il me dit oui
elle va mourir j'ai dit mais docteur
faites quelque chose pour que ça aille
plus vite il m'a répondu mais madame je
ne peux rien faire d'ailleurs elle n'a
rien demandé et je ne peux rien faire
alors ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir et
j'ai très vite rédigé des directives de
volonté Comé dit aujourd'hui il n'y a
que 2,5 % des Français qui ont rédigé
leurs directives
anticipées Sophie oui j'ai eu la visite
ce matin d'une NS adérante et elle est
venue porter ses directives anticipé
alors j'ai pour Sophie responsable des
directives à la DMD si aussi peu de gens
les ont écrites c'est qu'elles sont
méconnues mais mais pas
seulement il s'agit de de de confronter
cette idée de mort de déchéance de de
fin de vie c'est pas enfin en tant
qu'être humain on n' pas envie de de
confronter ça n'est-ce pas ensuite
souvent les personnes ne savent pas
parler de leur fin de
vie aujourd'hui les directives
anticipées ne s'imposent pas aux
médecins elles peuvent être rédigées sur
papier libre et sont valables 3
ans la loi de 2015 prévoit de les rendre
contraignantes pour le médecin de créer
un modèle officiel qui sera intégré dans
un registre nationale et leur validité
ne sera plus
limitée au Sénat pas de rassemblement
non plus sur les directives anticipées
un bras de fer s'engage entre les
défenseurs du texte et le noyau dur des
sénateurs les républicains ces derniers
estiment que le disposit
va trop loin ils vont de nouveau réussir
un coup de force et faire enlever du
texte le caractère contraignant des
directives anticipé par conséquent nous
proposons une autre rédaction
qui indique que le médecin prend en
compte les directives anticipées mais
qu'elle ne s'impose pas à lui c'est
effectivement une différence majeure
entre nous le médecin est là pour
prendre en compte les directives
anticipées mais doit garder son
appréciation et son
jugement merci Monsieur delè la question
de cette directive c'était doivent-elles
engager les médecins ou pas doit-on
laisser une marge de manœuvre au médecin
qui peut aussi avoir des éléments
d'appréciation de façon collégiale
notamment pour Marie sol Touren la
ministre de la Santé cette nouvelle
manœuvre vise surtout à vider la loi de
son sens je donne un avis défavorable
parce que de demander que les directives
anticipées ne s'impos pas au médecin
et ne s'inscrit pas là non plus dans la
perspective porté par cette proposition
de loi merci madame la ministre qui est
pour qui est
contre il est adopté s'il y a des
directives anticipées elles doivent à
notre avis elles doivent être appliqué
par le médecin qui est présent alors que
là tel que c'est on retombe comme
auparavant et ça veut dire qu'elles ne
sont pas opposables donc le médecin peut
faire ce qu'il
veut directives anticipées non
contraignantes sédation profonde mais
non continue le texte qui devait être
celui du consensus a été vidé de son
contenu détricoté par un petit groupe de
sénateur républicain mobilisé et qui a
su donner de la voix face à la
Commission et au
gouvernement là on est on est
effectivement dans un texte qui s'est
éloigné progressivement non seulement du
texte de 2015 mais qui en partie a remis
en cause le texte de 2005 donc je crois
que la première des choses à faire c'est
s'appuyer sur le texte 2005 don tout le
monde y compris au Sénat et y compris
les adversaires de la loi 2015 disent
qu'elle est très bien donc ne touchons
pas à la loi
2005 on a tousonnuel une dernière
question va être débattue celle du droit
d'accès aux soins palliatifs chaque
année en France il ne sont que 100000
personnes à en bénéficier pourtant les
besoins sont trois fois plus
importants bonjour bonjour bonjour vous
ça va ça veut dire quoi que ça
va les murs de cette chambre Thierry les
connaît par cœur il est cloué dans son
lit depuis 1 an on lui a découvert une
maladie orpheline incurable il y a 4 ans
depuis son état se dégrade pour soulager
ses douleurs une équipe de soins
palliatif vient régulièrement à son
domicile il me soulage il me soul dans
tout ils sont bien ils sont toujours là
il problèmes quand on a ils sont très
bien ils sont très bien je suis bien
entouré voilà comment tu le trouves
moralement Fatima est infirmière c'est
elle qui gère l'équipe de soins
palliatif à domicile elle vient voir
tiierry régulièrement en fonction de ses
besoins l'occasion pour elle de faire le
point avec les aides soignants sur
l'évolution de l'état de santé de thier
alors notre rôle c'est d'être en lien
avec les professionnels du domicile de
réfléchir avec eux comment maintenir
améliorer soutenir la présence du
patient chez lui c'est toi qui a le
dossier des patients hospitalisés chez
eux Fatima on suit une
quarantaine son équipe de soins
palliatif est financée par l'agence
régionale de santé mais clairement
manque de
moyens d'accord on ne peut pas dire que
c'est suffisant en terme de moyens hein
puisque nous sommes sur un bassin très
important un bassin géographique très
important et nous couvrons un nombre
deun population de plus de 625000
habitants donc on est une équipe
quasiment tout à temps partiel
et nous avons de plus en plus de
demandes de la part des profession de
santé des institutions et des familles
mais mises en lien par les
professionnels de santé ce qui signifie
que nous sommes de plus en plus
sollicité pour cette aide au maintien à
domicile en France des réseaux à
domiciles comme celui de Fatima sont
rares la loi Leonetti de 2005 devait
pourtant les développer tout comme les
unités de soins palliatifs dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui très inégalitaires
sur le territoire s'il y en a beaucoup
dans les grandes agglomérations elles ne
sont pas suffisantes dans les zones
rurales
idem pour les unités de soins palliatifs
qui se déplac dans les services des
hôpitaux les unités
mobiles un manque criant dénoncé par les
sénateurs les républicains qui demandent
au gouvernement d'inscrire l'égalité
d'accès au soins palliatif dans ce
nouveau texte je pense que ceux qui sont
pour ce texte qui le portent ne peuvent
pas ne pas entendre ce cri le cri des
territoires qui sont injustement traités
avec ces kirriel de malades qui ne
peuvent pas avoir accès aux soins
palliatifs alors que leur état devrait
leur permettre et qu'ils en souffre un
des soucis du texte et d'aujourd'hui et
de demain d'ailleurs c'est que on se
refuse en France avoir une politique
massive d'investissement en matière de
culture palliative en matière de so
palliatif c'est là qui est le problème
et surtout vous savez que 20 % de nos
concitoyens ont accès à ces soins
palliatif 80 % n ont pas accès et ces
soins palliatifs c'est le privilège de
quelques territoires la plupart de nos
territoire n'y ont pas accès et je
considérais avec d'autres que le
problème le plus urgent c'était pas
tellement de faire une nouvelle loi
c'était d'abordessayer de traiter ces
problèmes très
concrets lespporteurs Gouvernement
partage ce constat mais estime que cette
question doit être traitée dans le cadre
du financement de la
santé il faut développer les soix
palliatifs c'est quand même avant tout
un problème purement financier et ça ça
se décide dans le PLFSS d' dans le
budget de financement de la sécurité
sociale donc c PLFSS ce genre
d'amendement réapparaissent ça au
contraire est tout à fait d'accord
personnellement j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer réexpliquer mais ils nont pas
voulu suivre au PLFSS et bien nous
réclamerons et nous inscrirons les
moyens financiers nécessaires pour que
le développement des soins palliatifs se
fasse sur l'ensemble du territoire mais
l'argument des rapporteurs ne convint
pas les autres groupes politiques se
Rall au républicains alors au risque de
surprendre moi je pense que c'était
plutôt bien comme amendement et il me
semblait alors que je défends une
position différente pour le reste du
texte je me sentais tout à l'heure un
petit peu isolé là-dessus je pense que
le préalable c'est les soins palliatifs
pour tous je m'aperçois avec
stupéfaction que ça pose un problème la
parole est à Madame David je vais vous
étonner à mon tour mais je suis sur la
même position que vient de défendre ma
collègue Corine bouchou la déclaration
d'intention était là elle était ferme et
c'était des soins palliatifs pour tous
sur tout le
territoire s'il suffisait d'inscrire les
choses dans la loi lorsqu'elles doivent
aller de soi pour que les choses se
réalisent ce serait tellement simple
j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure que je
présenterai que je proposerai la semaine
prochaine à un comité de pilotage un
plan triénal de développement des soins
palliatifs et des unités de soins
palliatifs dont un des axes majeurs sera
la réduction des inégalités sur le
territoire et pas simplement entre les
territoires lorsqualin clè et moi-même
avons remis le Rapport au Président de
la République sur la proposition de loi
nous avons dit tous les deux que la
priorité des priorités c'était le le
développement des soins palliatifs et la
formation des soignants et qu'aucune loi
si parfaite soit-elle et celle-là est
imp parfaite comme toutes les lois
humaines et bien ne peut être efficace
s'il y a pas ces deux
éléments fin de l'examen du texte au
Sénat et fin de partie pour les
rapporteurs et le gouvernement qui
sortent grand perdant de cette séquence
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que le
travail qui avait été fait par nos trois
rapporteurs était un travail excellent
et que ce travail a été détricoté et si
c'était pour en arrivé à la rédaction
qui ce soir se trouve sur la table il
n'était pas nécessaire de proposer un
texte de loi
nouveau des rapporteurs déçus qui
estiment leur travail gâché par quelques
sénateurs qu'il qualifie de conservateur
c'est un texte de de conservateur euh
peut-être guidé aussi par des des des
des
arrièrespensées religieuses quelque peu
intégriste j'ai pas peur de de le dire
et je trouve que allez je me lâche la
charité chrétienne c'est pas ça si on
commence à s'invectivver pour dire il y
a parce que derrière le mot
conservatoire en France c'est pour dire
voilà il mérite pas d'exister c'est faut
pas s'attarder sont des
réactionnaires vous savez la réaction où
est
je ne traite
personne avec des qualificatifs qui
pourraient être péjoratif ou qui
pourraient déclasser leurs arguments je
pense que l'honneur de ce genre de débat
c'est que chacun puisse essayer
d'argumenter sur ses convictions
oui
oui quelques jours plus tard à
l'occasion du vote solennel sur
l'ensemble du du texte les rapporteurs
prennent le revanche le texte vidé de sa
substance article par article est
finalement rejeté par le Sénat j'ai à la
fois d'infinis regret qu'un consensus
qu'un rassemblement ne se soit pas opéré
au Sénat comme il s'était opéré à
l'Assemblée nationale mais je suis
soulagé que la sagesse de la Haute
Assemblée l' est amené à rejeter ce
texte qui va permettre au travail de
reprendre dans des conditions plus
simples à l'Assemblée
nationale au jeu des affrontements le
Sénat sort perdant en rejetant la
proposition de loi sur la fin de vie
dans quelques mois les députés
reprendront l'examen du texte en seconde
lecture dans sa version
initiale
X